pretty tonight a Facebook Friday Eve
extravaganza your questions for the hour
this Thanksgiving you posted them on our
page facebook.com slash the five fnc so
let's begin the first question I shall
go to you Kimberly oh of course
where are the questions by the way here
they are well prepared well I just
walked in here this is from Judy s what
balloon would you be in the Macy's
parade great question is I don't think
they're it but I don't think I exist yes
I know white well she should have a
balloon there's a Wonder Woman balloon
this year then I should definitely be
the Wonder Woman that look very very
good for a lot of very good reasons one
you're full of a lot of hot air balloon
would you be
I like Snoopy Snoopy Snoopy my favorite
my favorite he's really great excellent
what about you just I'm not familiar
with the parade Blinn situation if you
have any options yes you have the Grinch
fine you asked for an option
resemblances I'll be the Grinch unpack
that one what about you Dana
I'm really like Kermit Kermit frog
that's good I always loved Kermit that's
a crowd favorite too yes all right I
thought you weren't gonna be Elf on a
shelf you know that's an that's just not
nice what this is supposed to be like
djembe lenses I know I know
okay ooh interesting question this one
is from Debbie oh I will go to you Dana
although we probably know what the
answer is with this which of the former
presidents would you like to have it
your Thanksgiving dinner and why pick
one that you haven't already at dinner I
would stay silent Cal ooh didn't say a
lot Calvin Coolidge Jenner would be over
faster no but I would like to ask him
how he restrained himself because the
office is very powerful and he didn't
actually do a lot of things he was like
let's let's just let the country be yeah
yeah yeah no entry here is a businessman
what about you Juan you're a historian
or so you claim I don't claim
[Laughter]
obviously abling can be fabulous be
awesome to sit and talk to on estate but
and then when you come forward in time I
think that's it's so interesting to me
that Harry Truman had to make so many
key decisions especially use of the bomb
yeah so I would say yeah I would sit
with those two hmm what about you you do
that a lot you look at me and then you
say Jessie Lincoln - because he's skinny
he's probably not going to eat a lot
which means more for me I would say JFK
Wow why because I think he's very
fascinating there's something I'm
towards their conversation
ya know I witness I would want to talk
to him about it was a very interesting
time in history at a time before he was
assassinated and the Cuban Missile
Crisis know something I'm interested at
the table - oh why not - for one at the
table I would choose ulysses s grant oh
yes you know why no you know already
you'd already have the flask with him in
case we ran out of booze did you even
read his memoirs I actually did a book
report on him in eighth grade so I know
a lot about him or at least I know what
the Encyclopedia Britannica told me no
but what she asked was a really good
question because that's the best
autobiography of a president you know
who wrote it who Mark Twain really
mm-hmm
see we learn something every day here at
the five and then we choose to forget it
immediately afterwards all right number
three third question Jennifer B what is
your specialty dish
keep it clean that you take to someone
else's house for Thanksgiving let's
start with one well it's not me
it's the least my wife she takes
sauerkraut and this is so interesting
because not flattering it's you know for
me I'm not a big fan but turns out it's
a tradition in her family right and you
hate your wife sauerkraut
you're not a big fan it's true love
anybody sauerkraut no it is pretty it's
pungent its pungent heart but what is
really interesting to me is when I first
became aware of this I would say how
come you guys cook sauerkraut because
they would have other things like pigs
feet you know and sort of black food
right but then they had the sauerkraut
and it turns out that part of her family
is of German heritage until they make
sauerkraut Wow now the Germans allowed
to celebrate Thanksgiving well why not
what's wrong with Germans you know what
Greg complains about identity politics
the biggest single ethnic group in
America is German okay I was just
thinking about German proper but that's
fine don't politicize the holiday Dana
wine wine I was gonna say why not gonna
pick something else really the wine
mm-hmm nobody wants me to bring anything
else believe me come on you can cook in
brilli I thought about your case though
yesterday by the way can't really take
that to Thanksgiving
no but I was thinking why because it's
not American so bigotry here is very
taking my turn
yes I would love to bring and I'd like
to bring to anybody banana pudding from
Magnolia Bakery and also one of their
delicious apple pies and a pumpkin pie
for dessert nice man that banana pudding
people Magnolias happy to see leave
anybody out is that it you know I'm with
kg on the desserts I'll bring a pumpkin
cheesecake pumpkin pie cheesecake you
make the cheesecake absolutely not okay
but I must say pumpkin cheesecake is
heavy yeah I like the banana pudding and
of course if you go across here and they
had that what is that lemon cake I only
bring prescription medication and I
don't share that gets me through the
evening can you mix it with your wine no
I don't yes America don't do that
Michelle see asks if you could ban one
I am Jesse this goes to you from the
Thanksgiving menu what would it be
Juan's wife's our crop I mean what's to
ban it's all good is it stuff giblets
come giblets are disgusting giblets
what's that like they get him out that's
what they do they should get them out
pull that out the plastic bag inside oh
it worked out does that cook I mean it
work you know no one laughs when was the
last time you cooked a turkey Kimberly a
turkey quesadilla what would you ban oh
I would ban first of all not a big fan
of onions number one but not but there
was a plate of them anywhere yet this is
gonna seem weird what I don't really
love sweet potatoes I am a gigantic
that's controversial of mashed potatoes
but I wouldn't ban sweet potatoes
because so many people I love adore them
I think this is gonna end up on all the
blogs they're gonna come after you
Kimberly you might want to issue a
statement ahead of time so this has to
just you know just between the five of
us and the millions watch but if
somebody in my family makes creamed
cauliflower it's like wow this isn't I
don't know what to say
yeah I know anything but creamed spinach
is the only thing I can eat creamed
that's good like your stomach is
supposed to be the green bean casserole
oh don't like that especially with
almond chips on top of it they're always
trying to make it creative if it's not
good at its base it's never gonna get
good yeah when you try to trim a tree
trainer a setup you can't you know you
can't dress up Quasimodo recently I have
become a fan of Brussels sprouts and you
know why because they they do them in a
way that they become crisp on the
outside
you can like fry them a bit like it's
just put some bacon and it's like that
you do that area town you have to drive
by really quickly that's what a Brussels
sprout smells like it's right by you
is that to know when you walk by ah well
you know he kind of got there first with
that joke but it's okay I would say I
would ban Turkey
I think turkey is overrated it's a very
dry boring meat like you're not cooking
it very moist and succulent if it was so
good why would you have gravy okay you
don't put gravy on steak because steak
doesn't need gravy sauce on steak
sometimes that's strange
so your analogy kaput no idea you could
deep-fry it and they have all those like
cool jumpy fires are started by deep
frying a turkey 16 million a year
turkeys are ugly and strange and
shouldn't be eaten they should be pets
this is Thanksgiving good fella I know
that yeah I know I know have a big
chicken
let's chicken a big dick all right this
is from Dolores I'll go to you Dana what
do you do after Thanksgiving dinner do
you watch football play games take a nap
when I was growing up we started a
tradition of going to the movies after
Thanksgiving dinner but I think we're
eating later this year and we're guests
of someone else I'm gonna I'm gonna try
to get him to play charades
yeah fun that is fun yeah good she's
good
I hate charades I'm not that good really
here's good but I remember when we
played at your house that time in South
Carolina you know when Greg wasn't you
know oh look there are a lot of people
who can't play charades so I just find
this whole game a little bit of pressure
why what do you do after Thanksgiving
dinner I leave best guest on the planets
watch where you go we go to so I have
Thanksgiving dinner at my brother's
house and then we have dessert coffee
all that at my wife's brother's house
mm-hmm
and then I fall asleep yeah even like
any of the food anywhere at sea no I do
like food one I mean our Jessie get you
too confused all the time yeah JW so I
avoid doing any dishes and then I keep
drinking and watch football mmm there
you go mmm not like a great guy to have
a real team player
um
I help with the dishes always very good
at doing dishes and cleaning up and
wrapping up the leftovers and then I'd
love to watch football and also probably
have a glass of wine that's nice
usually what I do is I just wait for
somebody to pick me up the police are
usually pretty nice about it they have
my own cell and your unicorn sweater
remember the time Dana disinvited you to
the Thanksgiving dinner yes that was
great
come on over I went over the
Thanksgiving dinner because I was
inviting and I wasn't hosting I was
going to somebody's house and I don't
really know well I know those people
well and it was a nice thing and I was
like oh he doesn't running where to go
let's have him come but then I thought
oh he's gonna hate it and he's gonna be
naked gonna be so me he's like he's not
gonna like it
so then I disinvited him but out of
you're out of concern for your
well-being I want you to be happy
Oh fantastic we'll just so you know I
had a great time alone weeping in a
closet stabbing my dana perino doll that
I made out of old socks alright last
question from Paul Kay let's go to you
Kimberly how soon do you start listening
to Christmas music um I would say a safe
bet would be December 1 mmm my little
Pandora my so no so then you can put
like the little Christmas stations I
don't think it's quite cheerful one well
this is a big complaint for me because
I'm a big fan of channel 70 on XM which
is love songs mm-hmm do you know that
member first they change to Christmas
musics wrong Thanksgiving you'd be
pretty angry but also I mean what crass
commercialism I mean they just want you
to but not you know I'm even Black
Friday now really is now the Monday
before Thanksgiving yes it's terrible
they need to be native as well Jesse
Peyton why do they need to rename that I
just find the term Friday to be
offensive but it's fun they could get a
lawyer no I'm fine December first bring
it on I'm ready
Dana I only I never would actually
choose to play it it just happens to be
around everywhere like what I went to
get a manicure the other day I'm
like early November and they're already
playing it mm-hmm will manicure
what will manicure why does it have to
be manicure more manicure practice
saying that interesting fact about
Christmas music it's terrible because
they know if you think about it it would
never if it was if Christmas music was
so good they would be played year-round
this year so they've wasted on us for
one month because they can't no one can
stand it oh that's not true oh it's
terrible because I think you know music
right Phil Spector's Christmas music
yeah outstanding that wall of sound
where is he now ears celebrating life
you listen to the one to take it though
yes so we I think we can all agree hear
Christmas music yeah